the gyro can experience well I have a
van der Holyfield we're scheduling
Evander Holyfield I'm excited huge
Evander Holyfield fan but he was one of
the rare guys that put on the mass and
moved up from cruiserweight to
heavyweight and [ __ ] still never got
tired
I mean Evander never got tired ok put
the word crazy work ethic and he was a
guy that got thick and muscular but
didn't slow him down it enhanced him you
know especially when you get into like
the Tyson fights like that mutt that
muscle didn't hold impact at all and he
was [ __ ] jacked he was he was
comparison to cruiserweight arounder
Holyfield you were getting heavyweight a
friend with like the riddick bowe fights
he is gonna [ __ ] you cut don't yes
chiseled yeah so that's what Tasha
should do she cut cut down a little bit
chisel whup it gets her get mobile do
you think this was something that he got
mad at Lennox Lewis for saying that he
needs to change camps do you think that
makes sense maybe just he should sit
down what his team to figure out what he
went wrong it I don't think about him
think you should change everything the
word was that he had got knocked out in
training mm-hmm you heard that as well
my Joey
well if Terence Crawford her I won't say
it feels real or fake I'm just saying I
heard you heard it yeah but you know
most people heard the rumors go around
and everybody here and it's not even
true that could happen right like
Richard Gere with that jerboas ass
member that one kids we're kids there
was a rumor that Richard Gere had to go
to the hospital get a gerbil taken out
of his ass now I grew up in the East
Coast my friend Eddie grew up in
California he heard the same story I was
like this is the same goddamn rumor like
how this room we get across the country
with the same age right no internet the
rumor made it all the way across the
country when we were in high school so
was it true or not I think you'd get a
chair about yourself it's not worth the
embarrassment you take some time to go
to store buy some tweezers
but you're uh you don't need to go to
the hospital just get a mirror and some
tweezers we could handle this we don't
need to let everybody know our business
all right
the other one was Rod Stewart Rod
Stewart there was a rumor war in high
school was booked pre high school the
Rod Stewart had swallowed a bunch of
jizz and had to go to the hospital get
his stomach pumped it's probably some
guy who Rod Stewart [ __ ] his
girlfriend
Rod Stewart the bad guy yeah and I
probably when I hosted Fear Factor we
made people drink come drink drink
donkey come you could drink it you could
drink a lot of it and you're fine I
don't think you have to go the hospital
my experience on fear factor taught me
that I don't believe that
Rod Stewart never had that real problem
hey so did you ever do any attempts I
ate some [ __ ] they wouldn't let me try
any the stunts the insurance purposes or
you know there cause the insurance
doesn't the hosts just try it out for
front like I wanted to drive some the
cars off buildings and [ __ ] but they
wouldn't let me do we had one where they
hit a ramp off the top of a building
they hit a ramp and the ramp flipped the
car through the air and they flew and
then landed on these cardboard boxes
they stacked these cardboard boxes of
like several stories high and that's how
they would get these cars to land softly
so the car would boom hit the cardboard
box and just slowly sink down and then
they would use a crane flip the car over
and then they could use that car again
it didn't even get damaged Wow so these
people would fly this [ __ ] car off
you look like the craziest amusement
park ride ever
easy I'll do it for the promo like I run
I be cool with jumping out the plane
yeah we didn't do any of that but we
didn't have people bungee cord jump off
of a [ __ ] helicopter that was crazy
we had a people with a cord that was
attached to a helicopter and then they
were hooked up to a tree and they had to
unlock themselves in the tree they had
only got a ring of keys there to find
the right key in a certain amount of
time and then when they did it they
unlocked and betraying they went flying
through the air because they were
attached to a bungee cord and the bungee
cord was underneath the helicopter it'll
go [ __ ] launching them out into the
middle of this crazy Canyon I was like
oh my god
someone's gonna die
gonna die this isn't worth it this job's
not worth it there was a couple times
where thought someone's gonna die hey
that's crazy stupid ridiculous I'm glad
I'm glad we got through it when nobody
getting hurt who came up with the stunts
Lorna there was a bunch of people they
had a whole team there's teams that
people that came out with the eating
stunts they were the B team stunt guys
and then the a team stunt guys was the
first first stunt and there was the C
which was like the big championship
finale thing it's ridiculous show last
time okay so watch the show all the time
yeah all of the time I can't believe
it's real i watch it to this day I was
like it's not really me I used to watch
jackass jackass amazing those guys are
alive so happy fine but I'm I'm making a
fourth movie rolling that dice there all
right someone's gonna die damn that's
crazy that I only seems attempts at it
Johnny Knoxville was a movie star for a
while
right is he still doing big movies yeah
he was doing big movies and then he was
still willing to let a bull hit him
he put a blindfold on stood in front of
a bowl and the bull just [ __ ]
launched him through the air blindfolded
Oh guys got [ __ ] up man I mean that is
there's they're taking some beatings yes
so we do laughter yeah yeah yeah okay
see what you do is control who gets
[ __ ] up right that's what I like about
boxing when I watch boxing Express at
the highest levels like one guys
controlling who gets [ __ ] up you know
yeah whether the guy liked it or not
whether other guy likes it or not
[Applause]